il
[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition devait y pv y paie aujourd'hui
avec et sidonie diaz bonjour
coordinatrice du lieu le lieu
le lieu c'est un espace culturel situé à
granby et puis dans quelques jours aussi
on perray-en-yvelines puisque vous
opérer une installation de ce côté là
dans les prochains jours on va en parler
plus en détail déjà présente et nous le
lieu est ce que le lieu saint l'espace
culturel pour faire vite oui tout à fait
c'est un espace culturel
alors on dit aussi que c'est un espace
de création artistique de création
artistique parce que haut lieu on
accueille chaque semaine des compagnies
ou des artistes professionnels ou
amateurs qui viennent profiter des
espaces qu'on leur met à disposition
pour créer leur spectacle pour répéter
pour écrire pour réfléchir
leur spectacle leurs oeuvres plastiques
voilà on accueille tout type de
d'artistes et de disciplines artistiques
c'est un lieu qui s'étend à tout de même
sur près de quatre hectares de forêt
c'est ça c'est immense oui c'est ça
c'est un terrain qui appartient à la
mutuelle arrêté p un terrain qui fait 7
hectares en fait à la base nous on
occupe juste un petit bout de ce terrain
voilà en passe de création uniquement
pour des artistes yvelinois où ce sont
des artistes aussi de passage dans le
département où ce c'est des artistes qui
viennent en fait de toute la france on
accueille on accueille quand même pas
mal de compagnie locale
surtout avatar et voilà des compagnies
professionnelles de toute la france on a
même eu une compagnie chilienne
il ya un an ou deux vous vouliez faire
du la culture de proximité aussi
impliquer un peu les les habitants du
territoire
c'est à dire que c'est ouvert en
permanence on peut venir rencontrer les
artistes et échanger les artistes
peuvent se nourrir aussi peut-être de
ces rencontres alors impliqué les uns
les habitants du territoire
effectivement c'est vraiment à la base
du projet en fait le projet du lieu il
est né grâce à la compagnie de théâtre
de rue
la compagnie née fugaces qui qui était
déjà implantée sur le territoire autour
de autour de gambe et galeries voilà et
accompagner les fugace à mener un projet
dit de territoire qui s'appelait
escapade où elles ont rencontré par ce
biais là beaucoup d'habitants des petits
vinh des petits villages aux alentours
et elles ont proposé à ses habitants de
participer à des spectacles
ça c'est la base du projet du lieu parce
qu'ensuite tous ses habitants se sont
réunis pour pour réhabiliter les locaux
pour n'occupe aujourd'hui à gambais et
pour construire le lieu donc vraiment
c'est les habitants qui sont à
l'initiative avec la compagnie
professionnelle des fugues as du projet
du lieu ça a permis de donner une
seconde vie à ce lieu qui était
complètement abandonné 1
c'est ça ouais c'est ça aujourd'hui
combien de compagnies sont installés
combien d'artistes
alors il
en fait le lieu aujourd'hui est associé
à trois compagnies professionnelles
d'accompagner les fugues as donc la
compagnie les armoires pleines et la
compagnie caractère c3 c3 compagnie en
fait opèrent de plus en plus d'actions
de
voilà d'action culturelle sur le
territoire yvelinois surtout du sud
yvelines et par ailleurs on accueille
une quarantaine de deux compagnies par
an voilà presque chaque semaine c'est du
bouche à oreille c'est à dire que c'est
un lieu un peu j'imagine
il n'est dit aussi assez atypique qui
doit attirer les artistes dont on entend
parler de ce lieu on du lieu et on vous
contacter pour ça oui c'est cela le
bouche à oreille fonctionne de plus en
plus sont plus en plus de visibilité
dans le réseau voilà des des compagnies
notamment des des compagnies d'arts de
rue par la présence d fugace mais aussi
de compagnies locales etc
les compagnies qui viennent passer une
semaine en général en sorte ressourcer
et très contente et du coup on en parle
elles ont parlé à des amis etc donc on a
de plus en plus de demandes
effectivement donc là le projet a déjà
quatre cinq ans derrière derrière lui
d'exercice du côté de granby le bilan
est plutôt positif
oui nos vies dans les très positif
vraiment on a avec avec le collectif du
coup le collectif les gens du lieu qui
compte les habitants qui sont à
l'initiative de ce projet et les
compagnies on est on voit là on a
vraiment monter un projet un lieu qui
qui nous ressemble qui ressemble un peu
à tous parce que c'est aussi un lieu
d'expérimentation en fait on
on se réunit on réfléchit à ce qu'on
pourrait faire ce qui nous fait vibrer
un petit peu ce qu'ils voient là on
expérimente de plus en plus et est là le
lieu tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui nous
convient bien et en même temps ça évolue
tous les jours on n'a pas vraiment une
base très fixe en fait on on tâtonne on
expérimente en fonction des dévoila des
opportunités aussi des associations des
partenariats qu'on fait sur le
territoire opportunités justement
développement c'est aussi la kz2 de
développement pour le lieu il y aura
bientôt les lieux on peut dire puisque
ce sera du côté aussi du
perray-en-yvelines l'installation est en
train de se faire on a vu quelques
images de granby on va voir quelques
images du père est aussi pendant que
nous parlons
comment ça va se concrétiser sur le
perray-en-yvelines alors le projet du
perray-en-yvelines en fait comment on en
est venu là bas en fait au lieu à gan b
on a une
une situation pas forcément très pérenne
parce que on est en bail précaire c'est
à dire que voilà on n'a pas vraiment de
visibilité à long terme
donc du coup on s'est mis à en fait on
veut faire continuer ce projet et ce
projet de territoire est partout sur le
territoire notamment du parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
et du coup on a cherché un nouveau lieu
où on puisse avoir plus de plus de
visibilité plus de pérennité et et on a
répondu à un appel à projet qui a été
proposé par l'amérique du
perray-en-yvelines sur un bâtiment donc
le 33 rue de chartres au père d'enis
flynn voilà on a répondu à cet appel à
projet qui se veut être un projet à
caractère social et intergénérationnel
donc on se reconnaissait tout à fait là
dedans aussi parce que on est une
association culturelle artistique mais
vraiment on se rend compte de plus en
plus qu on est aussi dans le social est
dans l'intérêt général sionnel c'est
vraiment voilà c'est vraiment aussi une
base du projet durieux qui nous est cher
et et qu'on veut vraiment développer
on y trouvera la même chose que sur le
lieu du 2 de gambe et où l'idée c'est
d'évoluer un petit peu ce projet là
aussi et peut-être ma de permettre aux
gens de découvrir autre chose
alors ça va pas être tout à fait la même
chose parce que de toute façon du fait
que ce soit pas au même endroit l'année
les choses changent et doivent
et doivent s'adapter en fait opérer en
yvelines on va être plusieurs
associations à s'occuper de ce lieu
alors le lieu
le lieu nous le lieu va être
gestionnaire principal du site et
d'autres associations vont travailler
avec nous pour proposer des activités
ponctuelles ou régulières à savoir une
association qui s'appelle les pipelettes
qui est une association d'une épicerie
participative une association qui
s'appelle cycle et recycle qui voilà qui
propose des ateliers de réparation de
vélos ou des vélos écoles et puis alors
une association aussi qui propose de
faire des petits objets avec les
personnes âgées etc et une association
de d'histoire et de patrimoine qui
raconte l'histoire du perray-en-yvelines
c'est avec toutes les associations avec
ses forces vives
on va se compléter on va proposer un
projet encore plus encore plus riches
quoi et puis fait avec avec encore
encore de nouvelles personnes et voilà
c'est comme ça qu'on avance aussi au
lieu c'est avec les savoir faire avec
les envies avec
avec tout le monde tous ceux qui veulent
mettre la main à la pâte
j'ai en perpétuelle évolution c'est la
nature même on a bien compris de de
l'initiative
si on parle un petit peu des rendez-vous
qui sont prévus parce que le 6 octobre
déjà pour le père et ce sera un grand
moment pour le lieu oui tout à fait
alors la mairie du perray en yvelines a
proposé aux associations qui vont
s'installer au 33 rue de sharp de faire
des journées de programmation éphémère
pour commencer à se faire connaître des
habitants donc des paires autant et
perrotine et donc du coup là cet automne
les associations ouvre chacune leur tour
les portes du 33 rue de charte pour
voilà pour faire connaissance et pour
présenter nos activités
donc pour le lieu rendez vous le 6
octobre à 11 heures
on va commencer la journée par un
spectacle le dernier spectacle de la
compagnie des fugaces qui s'appelle
vivant qui en spectacle du coup de
théâtre de rue en déambulation dans le
quartier autour du 33 rue du jard parce
qu'encore une fois il dessine n'est pas
de nous cloisonner mais vraiment de
sortir des murs un maximum et de
d'essayer de rayonner alors un maximum
dans la rue dans le quartier puis sur
tout le territoire
il ya ce rendez vous là le 12 octobre à
joueurs qu'on chante quand il ya un
événement aussi qui est organisé voilà
c'est ça un rendez-vous du lieu dans le
cadre de l'événement qui s'appelle le
jour de la nuit donc organisé avec la
ville de jouars-pontchartrain et avec le
plan d'autres associations de la ville
une déambulation nocturne donc voilà
pour sensibiliser sur ce qu'est
l'éclairage nocturne
voilà et le 19 octobre et ont agressé
on retourne à gand vais voir là dans
notre lieu et on fête l'anniversaire du
lieu ça va être une soirée surprise
on voit là on n'en dit pas plus le
public va arriver et puis il va se
passer tout un tas de choses je reviens
sur les réactions du public justement
comment ils ont ils ont découvert
comment il s'en approprier un petit peu
le site sur granby il ya une surprise au
début de voir un peu ce qui était fait
et puis après est ce qu'il ya des
revenus plus régulièrement peut-être
aussi des habitués oui oui oui alors en
fait en nous tenant septembre 2015
il ya le chantier de réhabilitation qui
a commencé qui a duré à peu près un an
donc pendant un an il y avait quand même
une trentaine de personnes qui sont des
habitants du coin qui ont réhabilité le
lieu donc déjà on avait de la visibilité
la compagnie les fugace en amont de ce
chantier avait déjà fait un projet un
projet de territoire à gambais donc les
gens connaissaient mais fugace
connaissent l initiative est donc passé
donner des coups de main et c est l
inauguration en octobre 2013
et puis donc on a reçu plus de 400
personnes
et puis et puis voilà après on n'a pas
de baiser on a à grand baie il n'y avait
pas de d'événements
très régulier voilà on faisait des
événements alors à peu près de deux fois
par an des gros événement ouvert au
public
et puis quelques petites sorties de
résidence donc où les artistes qui
étaient accueillis pendant une semaine
présenté leurs étapes de travail et la
wii avait des habitués qui venait à
chaque sortie de résidence assisté à ce
petit bout de ce spectacle qui était en
train de se créer et devenez ainsi un
petit peu complice de la création du
spectacle de par les retours qu'ils
avaient ensuite avec les artistes et les
échanges pour toujours invaincus peuvent
améliorer les choses
et voilà vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
lieu à granby pour découvrir le travail
qui est mené on a parlé un petit peu des
différents rendez-vous et puis et
bientôt opéré en yvelines également dès
le 6 octobre notamment à tous les
renseignements sont à retrouver sur le
site qui a s'est affichée comme
d'habitude sur votre écran merci
beaucoup sidonie dit amercia
coordinatrice du lieu d'être venu pour
sauver grippé
[Musique]